can you take us through your outlining
process sure
generally what I'll do is I'll start
with the premise line I'll write out a
premise line sort of basically for me
like the foundation of the script a
couple of sentences take you know let's
start to finish and then I'll expand
that into nine and maybe two three four
pages this is sort of righted in
sections so I'll divide it into into
three basically if it's a movie three
movie acts but you know in more in
quarters so it's like the equivalent of
a quarter quarter quarter quarter which
takes me through the four quarters or
the three acts of the of the movie so
it's I can keep it because one of the
things that happens when you start
writing it for me and when I start
writing out and at writing an outline in
you know prose form is that you know if
you don't if you don't from me if I
don't kind of stop you know stop writing
a certain point you know you end up with
let's say your outline is four-page
you're writing it just outlining four
pages the first two pages may really
only be the first quarter of your script
because you know you you know you end up
writing so much and then then you have
to really then ultimately you end up
with kind of you know disproportionate
disproportionate acts so basically I'm
just trying to write it as tightly as I
can and I'll write it long and then I'll
then I'll edit it but in the end I want
to end up with kind of four relatively
close descriptions of each quarter okay
let's say that's that ends up being
three four pages whatever then if it's
on if it's an assignment then I'll
they'll give it to the executive or
whatever I'll get notes on it rework it
and then if it's not for me I'll do the
same thing for myself and then what I do
is I divide the and this was a you know
really a credit writers who can't do
this because they really this was kind
of the way they taught me how to do it
and how I always do it now and I taught
other people and I I think it's pretty
it's one of those things that's just
sort of like I don't think it's an
uncommon way to do it but it kind of
boils it down to I think a really
effective way of doing it is that you
divide I divided up into twelve
sequences three sequences in the first
act six in the second act and three in
the third act of equal weight so
basically you know if you're writing 102
we page script or you know it's ten
pages of sequence if you're right if
you're more like 100 page script it's
eight or nine pages of sequence and I
feed out the list of scenes so I'll take
a right turn I create a sequence
sentence you know so this was sequence
one two and three so out of that
sequence sentence that I write right out
pulled from the outline the longer
outline I then write a list of the
scenes that will comprise that that that
that's sequence so I'll put like what
the scenes in a row and then I'll figure
out how many pages that scene will
approximately be so that I can add it up
add up each sequence and say at the end
those six scenes will equal eight and a
half pages or something and it's an
estimate it may sometimes I'm very off
but it's an estimate then this is just
my kind of organized way of doing it you
know and how I don't get lost in the
process you know and I really kind of
stay on track this is just mine
everybody has the way of doing it and so
I did that so ultimately you end up with
basically 12 series of single obscene
lists so at which should ultimately when
you add it all up should equal you know
whatever your page desire page count is
100 105 pages under 20 pages an estimate
and then I take that I put that onto my
final draft that list onto my final
draft and I create a slug line over each
one
you know interior living room night
exterior you know baseball field date
whatever and and so I have the line and
then I what what the scene is about and
then I have the slug line so basically
what I end up with is a whole written
script except for that dialogue
essentially and then you go in and just
you know you craft it and to me it's a
very step-by-step process so it's like
an accordion you're constantly expanding
that accordion until you have the whole
script written so that back that that
works for me but everybody does it
differently whether writers who say they
don't do outline and if they can do
that's more power to them you know I
everybody you know I look at like some
of the Coen Brothers movies you know
some of the great movies of our time
right amazing stories incredible
character you know
incredibly creative those are not all
necessarily outlined how they align but
but they don't feel as specifically
structured as most movies you see some
are some aren't I think they take you
know they just they're really brilliant
you know I think they're just able to
you know they're able to infuse their
stories in their own world in their own
structure you know for example if you
can do it it's great I I think I do
I've just seen too many writers who get
lost in the process because they have
been sort of laid it out enough ahead
ahead of time again it works for me I
and I never look at it at any of this
like oh it's putting me in a box or I'm
you know using a formula it's not at all
it's just it's how I write and
especially when you're on a deadline and
you know you have a limited amount of
time to write something it really helps
me you know you know move more quickly
and and having giving a system of sort
of checks and balances on my material
and and kind of force it helps me not
over write as well and ultimately maybe
spend not what lose too much time on
ston any material that I'm not
alternately going to put in the script
so what's your nemesis when you're on a
deadline you know changes too many
changes along the way you know kind of
any wholesale changes that may sort of
crop up you know it's never a problem
you know kind of all it's just shifting
something rearranging something changing
dialogue you know threading something in
but sometimes there's that wholesale
change like the whole you think
something's working in that just whole
concept is just not it's just not
playing and you know it's not going to
you know it's not going to it's not good
in the end you're going to be found out
and it's not going to work so it's like
listing out a whole part and putting it
aside and reconfiguring any when you
have to do that in the middle it doesn't
happen often and again I think if you've
got a strong outline and particularly if
it's if it's an assignment where you're
working with people and they're
approving an outline and they're in
agreement with what you've written you
kind of trust it to pretty much what you
know what you sold essentially but yet
too many changes on it when there's a
tight deadline can be really difficult
unexpected changes
you